>> Juan: THE CHILDREN’S
CLASSIC "PETER RABBIT" HAS
BROUGHT JOY TO MANY GENERATIONS.
THE STORY OF A RABBIT SPEAKING
INTO A FARMERS VEGETABLE GARDEN.
A NEW MOVIE ADAPTATION IS
GETTING BACKLASH.
PARENTS BOYCOTTING THE FILM IN
WHICH CHARACTER WHO IS ALLERGIC
TO BLACKBERRIES IS ATTACKED WITH
THE OFFENDING FRUIT.
SONY PICTURES FORCED TO
APOLOGIZE FOR THE FOOD ALLERGY
BULLYING, CALLING IT A SERIOUS
ISSUE THAT SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
MOCKED EVEN IN THAT CARTOONISH
OR SLAPSTICK WAY.
I GUESS THIS WOULD BE NEWS TO
WILE E. COYOTE.
HE TOOK A LOT OF ABUSE.
>> Kimberly: HE SEEMED TO LIKE
IT, WASN’T ALLERGIC.
>> Juan: HE WAS ALLERGIC TO
DYNAMITE.
[LAUGHTER]
THROW A BLACKBERRY INTO THE
VILLAIN WHO IS NAMED
MR. MacGREGOR.
THEY THROW A BLACKBERRY NOT
KNOWING HE’S ALLERGIC AND THAT
HE CAN APPLE ALLERGIC REACTION
THAT COULD BE FATAL.
>> Jesse: SOON YOU CAN’T EVEN
SAY BLACKBERRY.
THIS COUNTRY IS TOAST, JUAN.
IT’S OUT OF CONTROL.
STARTED WITH THE WAR ON
CHRISTMAS.
>> Dana: HERE WE GO AGAIN.
>> Jesse: SAFE SPACES, GENDER
PRONOUNS, BATHROOMS.
FOOD ALLERGY BULLYING IS
ACTUALLY A PHRASE.
WE USED TO HAVE KIDS THAT WOULD
WAKE UP AT 6:00 A.M. AND MILK
THE COWS, DO CHORES, WORKING THE
FIELDS.
NOW THEIR PARENTS ARE WHINING
ABOUT A MOVIE.
>> Juan: NOT EVERYONE HAS
COWS.
>> Juan: YOU ARE VERY
SENSITIVE PERSON.
DIDN’T GREG SAY ON THIS ISSUE
THERE REALLY IS A THREAT TO
CHILDREN?
>> Jesse: GREG MIGHT BE THE
VOICE OF REASON IN THIS WHOLE
THING.
TELL ME WHERE I’M WRONG.
>> Greg: WHEN I WAS LOOKING AT
THIS, I GO, IT’S A MOVIE.
IT’S NOT REAL.
IT’S A TALKING BUNNY BUT IF YOU
ARE WATCHING IT AND YOU HAVE A
KID WITH A SERVE YOUR ILLNESS IN
WHICH -- SEVERE ILLNESS AND THEY
ARE EXTOLLING A PRACTICE THAT
WOULD HARM YOUR CHILD.
FOR EXAMPLE, LET’S SAY THEY WERE
SLIPPING SUGAR INTO A DIABETIC’S
FOOD OR STICKING A HEMOPHILIAC
WITH A NEEDLE.
IN THIS, IT IS KIND OF THE SAME
THING.
IF YOU HAVE A POINT THAT THIS IS
ENCOURAGING SOMEONE, I DON’T
KNOW WHAT YOU COULD DO ABOUT IT.
THERE ARE SO MANY ACTIONS AND
MOVIES ENCOURAGING BAD THINGS
BUT YOU WOULDN’T HAVE MOVIES IF
YOU WENT AFTER EVERYTHING.
WHAT A CONTRAST BETWEEN NOW AND
THEN.
"PETER RABBIT" WAS ABOUT A
CHEERFUL RABBIT WHO ATE
VEGETABLES.
NOW IT IS A WALKING NONSENSE
MIGRAINE OF DIGITAL VOMIT.
SO MUCH STUFF COMING AT YOU.
>> Juan: WHAT ABOUT THINGS
LIKE PEANUTS?
A KID WILL SMEAR HIS HANDS WITH
PINEAPPLE AND TOUCH ANOTHER KID,
KNOWING THE KID IS ALLERGIC TO
PINEAPPLE.
>> Kimberly: OBVIOUSLY THAT IS
HORRIFYING.
MY CHILD WOULD NEVER DO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
YOU’VE GOT A COACH AND TRAIN
YOUR KIDS TO NOT BEHAVE THAT
WAY.
BE SENSITIVE AND BE EMPATHETIC.
WHEN I GO FOR RONAN’S
PARENT-TEACHER CONFERENCE, THEY
SAY YOUR SON IS VERY EMPATHETIC.
LOOKS TO MAKE SURE SOMEONE IS
PLAYING AT RECESS.
IF THEY ARE ALONE, HE ASKS THEM
TO PLAY.
I CARE MORE ABOUT THAT THAN WHEN
THEY SAY HE GOT THIS GREAT OR
THAT.
I WANTED TO BE A GOOD CITIZEN.
TREAT OTHER PEOPLE WITH RESPECT.
I FEEL HORRIBLY FOR PARENTS WHO
WORRY EVERY DAY ABOUT THEIR
CHILDREN WHO HAVE FOOD
ALLERGIES.
I HAVE FRIENDS WHO LOST THEIR
CHILDREN TO FOOD ALLERGENS.
IN ONE, THE PARENTS WERE
DOCTORS.
IT’S VERY DISTURBING.
I AM NOT A FAN OF THIS WHOLE
"PETER RABBIT" SITUATION OR
WILLY WONKA OR
"THE WIZARD OF OZ."
I FIND THE WHOLE THING
TERRIFYING.
>> Jesse: I LOVE WILLY WONKA?
>> Greg: THE GENE WILDER
VERSION IS AMAZING.
>> Kimberly: THEY DON’T LOOK
LIKE RABBITS.
THEY LOOK LIKE ROBOTS.
>> Dana: THERE WAS A CASE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
THE PINEAPPLE ONE AND THESE MEAN
GIRLS PUT PEANUTS IN ORDER TO
HURT ANOTHER GIRL.
I DO THINK, WE GREW UP WATCHING
CARTOONS.
YOU DIDN’T END UP STICKING
DYNAMITE IN ANYBODY’S HOUSE.
I THINK THIS MOVIE GOES THROUGH
THE ENTIRE PROCESS, THINK OF HOW